ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj e ho dovuto
iniziare questo video in un cinema
perché fa figo inizi non ho mai iniziato
un blog in un cinema una volta lo devo
fare non c'è nessuno stiamo per vedere
50 sfumature di grigio però non c'è
nessuno quindi posso tranquillamente
dire che un film porno ed attenti
ragazzi e prevede che sono video sono fa
vj dall'inizio del logo avete potuto
capire quanto sono una persona stupida
ma non ci voleva quello per capirlo
anche ragazzi sapete tutti che tipo nei
video iometti cappelli quelli strani che
metto di solito perché non ho voglia di
aggiustarmi i miei capelli quindi per
non far vedere quanto fanno schifo
metto i cappelli di solito è sì che lo
metto sempre gli stessi [ __ ] i
capelli per una volta ha voluto mettere
qualcosa di diverso
farò il blog così evento queste
ragazzine che possiamo cominciare
scusatemi se di sfondo non ho la mia
solita cameretta ma adesso ci arrivo non
vi tagliate ancora le vene tranquilli no
perché già lo vedono già attraverso la
webcam la vedo la gente che già si sta
tagliando calmi tivoli comincia ragazzi
partiamo con la fonte la settimana che
questa settimana è stata vinta da non mi
sono salvato il nome uccidimi senza
pietà perché la fa nata io oggi ragazzi
e diversissima da tutte le pratiche ori
che io abbia mai ricevuto fino adesso
praticamente ragazzi mi hanno fatto una
fan art video non so spiegare la guardo
insieme a voi così capita un attimino
sta cosa ecco l'acqua adattato che in
gioco della madonna che sono pero
ragazzi sono fa vj e benvenuti nel mio
video games cos'è sta roba tipo
interattiva cosa vuoi fare oggi io dico
io sarebbe un dialogo tra me
è un utente a caso è bellissima la
risposta ecco tu perfetto che se la
risposta che dovreste dare poi renderman
cat mario happy meals cat mario ovvio
già perché magari ma allora vi piace
veramente vedermi sclerare la verità è
che mi piace
ovvio da davvero davvero ragazzi vi
piace anche tu mi piaci tanto che se o
cazzo non ho capito un cazzo manco io
però è figo quindi ragazzine che
possiamo capire il suo cappello mi
saranno fastidio preferisco fare blog
così posto giusto mi chiedo sempre
perché non faccio una coop nei miei
video adesso ci siamo soli in una coop
fa vj e il ciuffo ribelle fanno il video
insieme una lui ha vita propria detto
esteri è che possiamo passare alle news
la prima chiusasi come se non l'avesse
ancora notato c'è uno sfondo nuovo
regalarci una ruga tipo e di beh è
strano che io faccio un video dove non
c'è il mio solito sfondo ball
gli switch date ancora c'è una
spiegazione spese terminati ma siccome
ragazzi devo fare un film è una cosa che
avevo già detto tempo fa ma per fare le
riprese mi sono dovuto trasferire da
adesso dovrò andare un po anche in giro
per il mondo per fare ste ripresa qui
perchè un pò un casino farò un casino di
blog in giro tipo in tibet con i monaci
roba pesante sto facendo questo blog
ragazzi in hotel gioca ovviamente non
sparò la mia tutta la mia vita in hotel
ci sono solo per due tre giorni poi avrò
un alloggio mia dove potrò registrare
più tranquillamente poi ovviamente
ragazzi sapete che io sono una persona
matura quindi quando sono in hotel
faccio cose tranquilla quindi non vi
aspettate che io sia tipo pazzo maniaco
[Musica]
altri ragazzi non so se sentite le
campane di sottofondo bellissimo finito
a cook ragazzi
la cosa [ __ ] di stelle che c'è una
vecchietta che alta mentre 10 tipo cosa
del genere che ti posta a pattugliare
fuori dalle stanze
quando ho detto bello a tutti ragazzi ha
preso un infarto secondo quindi ragazzi
a parte tutto sto casino voi non avete
idea non avete idea del casino che ho
fatto permette perché questa stanza
piccolissima guardate come cazzo ammesso
il compiuta c'è allora scrivania questa
questo eletto io la mattina scendo dal
letto inciampo qui
cado muoio e poi faccio i video c'è una
roba indecente ho messo un computer i 12
metri in una stanza che di due metri
quadri per fantastico passa la seconda
news che non è tanto la news ma è più
una domanda siccome non sono più a casa
di in questo momento non posso fare lo
scarta joe dei pacchi perché non è che
posso fattami scatoloni everywhere
quindi ragazzi volevo chiedervi secondo
voi potrebbe essere un'alternativa lo
scarta joe dei pacchi che faccio di
solito fatemelo sapere nei commenti e
fatemi sapere che cosa vorreste che io
facessi madonna al suicidio dei verbi ho
finito con le news rai ha detto questo
passiamo lo skal non posso farlo
scattato di pacchi sono un [ __ ] anno
annuncia annunciato che cosa faccio
adesso ti fai qualcosa anche tu
e adesso passiamo al suo fare sfoglia
bravo piccolo mio ragazzi e non so per
chiari in questo preciso momento mentre
cercavo le domande con screenato ho
trovato questa cazzo di foto nel mio
computer ma perché ha già camera mi ha
visto delle cose brutte non inquiniamo
anche questa grazie a una terra mi dice
favi ma ti rendi conto no favi non c'è
non sono inventato ma ti rendi conto che
nel video più cliccati questa settima
settimana c'è questo subito dopo i
vincitori di sanremo 2015 sei un
portento yes guarda il talento verona
dove guarda che roba
a deleghe ai play the game
ragazze
apprezziamo queste così di talento
italiano nel mondo
poi risponde me lo invento i famigli
dico a cazzola vi risponde nessun favi
ci parli delle tue paure lari dico
perché fa sempre figo dire di che cosa
mi cago addosso ready era interrogato e
io sono avevamo partenza l'aracnofobia
ma quella è ormai lo sa anche la
vecchietta che è morta in qua e tu e
pantofole e la pantofola questa la metto
quindi ragazzi a parte sta cosa
dell'arac non fobico che tanto lo sanno
tutti o una pace allora questo non ho
mai capito perché manco io però ho paura
dell'acqua alta cioè nel senso se mi
buttano in mezzo io sono fatto cinque
anni di nuoto quindi so nuotare prossimi
buttano in mezzo all'oceano tipo rimango
così dalla casa perché queste cose ce le
sadismo in questa domanda non so perché
emanuele size canzone preferita di
skrillex perché c'è un alieno nel
commento la mia di skrillex kyoto perché
sono una delle poche che so fare quindi
[Musica]
dovevo vantarmi di questa non scherzo
sono ben pirlo sarà malick faiz imita
enrico pasquale pratico io sono enrico
pasquale proprio co abbott a motta san
giovanni
ho 22 anni e sono un ragazzo carino e
quelle ragazze che mi piace a me mi
piace non biondi capelli neri matri
bellissimi set a vigna la vigna è viva
micheli provata fai dai te libro mai
letto dopo maze runner che l'ha scritto
giusto tranne ai prova pomeriggio n roll
e tu adesso faccio l'elenco ciao ne ho
letti un po adesso ora come ora mi sono
portato di allora io c'ho ecco adesso ci
ho visto quest che tipo è una serie che
va tantissimo in gran bretagna sempre
nel genere tipo fantasy praticamente
l'ho trovato per caso perché lo vendono
ovunque se in libreria che in edicola
quindi che cosa cazzo sto facendo
ho praticamente preso la via perché
fantasia o tipo esco di testa ad esempio
quando ci sono guai le lotte contro i
draghi tanto è bellissimo le lotte con
il drago sole cose più belle e io sono
un tipo troppo fuori sul fantasy andante
così comunque questo è detto questo
ragazzi concluso più confavi risponde è
stato scusate tipo uscito un po più
corto del solito blog
anche adesso tolgono scart aggio dei
pacchi solo oggi non potevo farlo semmai
capitasse che io non possa fare lo
scarto di pacchi per qualsiasi motivo
quale sarebbe un qualcosa che vi
piacerebbe che io facessi così oggi è
tutto un gesticolare a cazzo periodi
concreto ragazzi la favi domanda di oggi
è secondo voi dove cazzo lo devo mettere
sto compiuta ma devi sapere abbastanza
presto che domani mi devo alzare i
ragazzi dai video è piaciuto così
incassato quanto mi piace anche a pagine
facebook e come noi video trattando
iscrizione soste ore si discute ci
vediamo al prossimo video gallo ragazzi
questo è un telecomando che ho trovato a
caso in stanza